annie lausanne a chargé de mission
documentaire alors le fond musical de li
na s'est constitué dès les années 20 et
30 à partir du moment où la radio a pu
diffuser et très vite les orchestres de
la radio publique de la radio d'état ont
été créés de manière à pouvoir vraiment
diffusée est proposé au public de la
métropole et des colonies des concerts
mais aussi tout ce qui concernait les
personnalités du monde musical de
l'époque des chansonniers que ces
carafes à partir des années 40 nous
avons beaucoup de concerts qui ont été
enregistrés au théâtre des champs
elysées par l'orchestré national et qui
également comment s'est tournée mondiale
petit à petit donc de plus en plus
d'émissions voit le jour et puis
évidemment avec la construction de la
maison de la radio par de gaulle en 1963
là nous proposons un seul et même lieu
de production et de diffusion nous avons
une chaîne dédiée qui prend le nom de
france musique et on dédie une chaîne à
la musique tellement cette musique a
pris une place prépondérante dans cette
radio publique
on propose aussi de très grandes
tranches horaires dans les programmes
pour faire des retransmissions de
festival aix en provence c'est la roque
d'anthéron on crée aussi un festival
radio france montpellier
nous diffusons depuis les années 40 50
des grands festivals de jazz comme
antibes juan les pins comme la grande
parade de nice évidemment et puis jazz
in marciac qui même s'il était diffusée
sur france inter était là bas tous les
étés nous avons aussi beaucoup beaucoup
de représentativité de la chanson
française évidemment comme jacques brel
nougaro soit ils étaient invités soit en
diffuser leur concert avec des grandes
collections musicales du diffusion de
festivals ou des missions dédiées à ces
gens là
et puis évidemment beaucoup beaucoup de
grands musiciens de toutes les décennies
qui venaient jouer dans les studios de
la radio les dinu lipatti les grands
interprètes qui sont venus comme chet
baker thelonious monk bilé 25e me joué
en studio
[Musique]
depuis quelques années nous proposons
public soit professionnel avec inna
mediapro soit des publics plus
particulier avec madeleine où il n'a
point fr ou des clients spécifiques
nous proposons grâce à ces nouveaux
outils en fonte qui pendant longtemps
n'était pas tellement connu et
aujourd'hui grâce à la numérisation
ce fonds est connu dans le monde entier
pour les éditions sonore nous avons des
clients américains mais aussi japonais
et coréen espagnol faut pas oublier
aussi les diffusions les rediffusions de
toute cette matière d'archivés sonores
qui existe depuis les débuts de la radio
parce que la radio a toujours diffuser
ses propres archives et nous avons
toujours permis grâce à la restauration
et à la conservation de ces archives
musicales
les rediffusions entre autres évidemment
sur l'antenne de france musique avec les
trésors des archives ou à l'époque
s'appelait les grands concerts
d'archivés de la radio et puis aussi
évidemment en jazz l'émission de jérôme
badini les légendes du jazz qui diffuse
soit l'intégralité soit en partie les
grands cancer des grands musiciens qui
sont venus à paris et qui ont enregistré
dans les emprises de la radio
[Musique]